What do you see?
I think we all work too much.
I think we've been,
we've been brainwashed into being that
we have to spend all our lives working.
We never used to do that now before the
industrial revolution.
I mean,
one would sort of,
you know,
the Irish for instance,
they would plant the potatoes in the,
uh,
I suppose it would be the sort of winter
in the,
in the ocean.
They plant their seed potatoes and then
they would sit and they would drink and
they would sing and they would eat and
they would wait for the potatoes to come
up.
And then,
you know,
that was their life.
What's wrong with that?
What's wrong with it in,
in Spain,
uh,
going to sleep for three hours in the
afternoon.
It's wonderful.
It's so civilized.
But we are,
you see,
the problem is we're,
we're,
we're told that we're put on this planet
to work and we work from 8:00
in the morning till 5:00
at night or whatever.
And,
and if we're lucky we have a Saturday
off and Sunday off and then we can go
and buy things.
But I don't think that's how life should
be for all bankrupt.
We all owe billions of dollars and
billions of whatevers to somebody.
I'm not sure who it is we owe it to.
But then somebody out there who's a who
must be really pissed off.